Hello, welcome to the 5th session on the 2nd day of the Check Notice Science and Technology Symposium in a temple in Korea.
I will start by giving you information on the solid dream ground before the latest start
.  Please
feel free to enter it in the qna chat window at any time during
the presentation, and I will answer questions during the Q&A session. Then, I will introduce you to Agilent Manager Ji-Woon Kim, who is in charge of presenting this session.
4 Is it easy?
This is Kim Joo-hyun, who is in charge of double.
Pesticide residue analysis for safe food is one of the very important branches in the 10-minute industry
.
Especially in pesticide residue pills, the whole method is changing in line with the expanded implementation and the
increased cross Gangbuk is
more than in the metal data 1 world.  In
this time, we will introduce various piggy analysis technologies for
more accurate analysis of 5 pesticide residues in water, along with 1 Elent Trigger Taiwan's technology, which is specialized in this generation.
Recently, Xu changed from cans of pesticide residues to related municipal constitutional amendments in order to more efficiently test and analyze the taste of rice in the commercial district of
Chida.  It is to enlarge it to the level of 100 types of high. If
you simply look at it, it may look like a cut that reveals a little bit of the number of doors
.  On
page 500, which has been changed to 500 species, it is known that it reduces some of the items of the jeongseon line and makes quantitative items.
and this relatively
It is that it provides a pentas method that can handle it quickly and accurately in a complex way. In the
end, ps, that is, without a standard, grazing failure, light emulsion business management, special inspection, simultaneous
military eating, is it a situation that has no choice but to continue to increase like this?
And in this area, in the now changed test bed, the biggest challenge for the
analyst is how to quickly and accurately push the items that have not increased like
this.
Let's look back at
the analysis part of Jeong Seon-
gyeong medicine, which is listed in the number of times of practice by mixing medicines in the device food industry.  In
particular, the unknown hydration component that deceived the side always exists, and at the same time, a very small amount of table
stone is required, so the qualitative level of education is quite high on the 5th day.
It is stated that errors may occur. If
you look more closely at the work of delo pesticides, in order to be satisfied with the sincerity
, as shown in the figure here, as shown in the figure, the standard product of the standard product error os at the peak neck
knee time should be over.  It is first checked for cleaning and unreasonable with the same physical characteristics.
Here, at least two blood ties
must be monitored today to ensure
purity.  All of these are detected and the verification of the quantitative iron
is to send the size ratio of the qualitative iron to the computer to indicate whether this ratio is in the work here
.  When the line confirmation is completed, it is simpler than quantitative gusu-dong. In
other words, standardize the p10 area in quantitative aion. Sword for the picky area in water.
You can see one
Here, in order to minimize the touching teeth, the number of pre-senior members
does not exceed 2.
In the end,
it is better to put a lot of whole-handed Aion to confirm the correct quality, but if you put a lot of pie today, it will decrease.
Let's talk more about these parts here for a while, and let's go
ahead and explain how the body features are structural in the analyzer by 8 weeks of nose
less.  It's
also called A Peter. After all, only that substance that is colored in a very short time at a specific time is
so dark, and the
rest sometimes becomes like
this.  Time for the ions to pass is not secured.
If more children than this are seen darkly, then
the passage time for each will be cut in half
.  Because
Tami is time, the circle has no choice but to bounce. In the
end, if the number of mrms increases, the time for passing one ion will
inevitably decrease and become a sympathizer. In
particular, it is characteristic of ac with relatively short analysis time and wide peak
Compared to the size of their knowledge, they are directors with a strong
will.  Since the peak is wide, so I did lcm sms, and the symptoms
appear larger
. Then again, I wonder how to increase the qualitative quantification accuracy of the number of bae-ssi voting plas. In the
end, qualitatively 5  In
order to reduce the probability of those 5 people, you need to monitor two or more project Aions to
secure a qualitative confirmation oil and perform stable suit absorption.
The height
limit is a problem with the quantitative relationship due to the moving difference, and if
you reduce the positive ion for the sensitivity layer, you will
encounter the problem that the positive sensitivity is good
.
A situation arises in which a choice must be made. In most cases, there is no one, and if one is chosen, a
compromise is found and reached. However, in
order to solve this problem, Heilant developed
Taiwanese technology.
As shown in the above, Jeongseong iron specs are a technology that creates results and dramatically increases Jungseonghwa Kim Yu
. The important thing here is
that quantitative accentuators do not appear despite the expansion of many innocence
irons.  It is a unique
technology that is unique
to Taiwan. Why is the basic Taiwanese
mrm i+1 for additional purity confirmation sales? Tran's usual technology is Koyo
. Every time it is actually attached, it creates a spectral live based on the Geumyang Boy standard off
. That is, the medium  I'm making an announcement with the capacity applied.
Currently, the city constitution is outside. Nancy constitution uses voice prosecution.
Now, we can make a
matrix batch deduction.  Ham or the buff state may change, but the
couple  They thought of a new live every 5 map batches for the final 2.
Now the comparison again
makes the comparison between the spectrum and the sample step
on the substance in the real sample.
Not only does it work, but it also acquires data points in a minimal amount of time for spectral formation,
so I don't see any desensitization even if I put 6 of these 5 to me rather
than using 2 or 3 of the existing mrm.
There is a function that is described as a similar function as the flute ion function, which is part of the code application. Now,
when it is hidden, it is a function to insert a scan function.
Environment 2 types 3 types 10 types 20 types other than rt can be
applied in such an AC technique that is sufficiently separated, but it is impossible to
actually use it in the water, equivalent to hundreds of hundreds of thousands of dollars that must be provided now
.
Since the technology is an angle-to-point belt method, this technology has a
huge difference in practical sensitivity. It is
a technology that has already been used in Korea at the same time.
Let's take a look at the easy regulation
Helent lc qd table is the entry model Ulti-Kok model and the hex 7
bends and the high-end model hex candidates exist
, but the city constitution was produced with the most commonly used hex 7 0 and Lieutenant General and
Ah adapt
I checked the results of how the crabs come out with the minimum mass of the family by mass. This is
the third status of the deposit. I did a simple analysis on the young drug
for 340 fairies now.
You can see a sample of this acquired part  Yes, it's
budget ppb mre. Now
, you can see the results of high-sensitivity peaks that appear with such perfectly clean skin. Since
I use Ferre, I have to satisfy the criteria such as 10 Begins, so
now,
uh, to accurately quantify pb, lower than that  It becomes that
scenic spot No. 2 of concentration. So, from 3 ppb,
we started writing verification at the 3 ppb review level and analyzed it.
The same day looks like this compared to detection.
5 are produced like this, and if you want to secure a spectrum like this for all the fields of the 5 river funds,
a total of 25 mims will return at the same time in an instant.
However, only you, the tree now  Compared to the fine dam or
er suit iron carried out, the pickle draws the pickle and the
integer 2 temperature continues to take the peak hair, and now
checks the quanta yoga rachel, and the concentration on the peak as the area of ​​ion ion for this quantification
By the way, the trick is to obtain this additional library by acquiring data in this way
at a minimum of 1 p 2 p 3 p when the test is confirmed at a certain concentration at the time of multi-generation,
so matching the standard material part and the corresponding part of the sample  I did it.
I will provide information that can further confirm whether the foreign body is correct by looking at the number of my discards.
Lung Gillette is new to Dai Nam in order to minimize the loss of biliary tract due to the increase in the expansion bribery mrm transition
.  Again, it's enamel. If you don't see it, it
's
a technology in which each rt is accumulated for each material that ends up being dirty
.
Because this 1.25 cheater eg 2 pica appears  Between yo, the nodes are
0.5 oolong,
uh uh uh uh 2r, what if you look at 0 point treatment from spring to 1 point
treatment 5 times, then left and right, 0.5 ur jeongjonghwa.
Giving
you tally time and
securing a lot of refinement for 2 times Hey, the technique I asked is diverse. Tie it to the horse,
Yono Danyang Seahorse.
It
will be a tool for "
I'll seal it
"  Even though it is not a pesticide residue, it is incorrectly inappropriate, or it is
now
referring to such a part.
It became the smells.
I applied all the substances. Usually, about five mins per week in the world was
an evil pound that came out too little
.
If you put two in each bay, 600 times m goes in a lot, but
as you can see, as
you can see in reality, from 7 to 1440
Miamis, and about 1440 tails. 2 Under this condition, 10 1404 mre turners within 15 minutes
Detecting and confirming the peaks
Like this , Cerebi has already been completed .
Residual pesticide avoidance , and at that time , if you look at the first
hookworm , the purpose of using the existing mim in actual analysis .
to help you make more accurate decisions
Come back
. If you have two sons like this, you will eventually be able to sell a lot of results
and avoid unnecessary additional experiments.
Especially for simultaneous 5-person attachments, the number is well adapted to the year 10,000.
It is the same as the currently expanded eunuch constitution. Since it is a
little closer to 300, I couldn't put much of m.
It's going to be a
dongja here I use the whole s at the end c Pulse wave gt that occurs
to solve that problem It's a specialized skill What is
this part?
It is now the law to extract and use the recovery rate as a whole. So,
then 7 yards and 2 of unwanted collateral substances were extracted more than expected.
False positives and positives are often caused by drugs that make these parts
appear to be pesticides when they are not actually
the substance but
not the pesticide.  It is not possible to satisfy all 2cd 100% big news with Apple,
but in that part, the technology that is more advanced than the current technology will now help data gray.
No matter how much the light
was detected with the addition of the b line allowing the
aburi rt is slightly out of line and the qualifying session seems to be a shoe, I saw a bus now
rt
appears like this, the standard tab here is now,
yes, 0 points open for 0 points,
and the Berkeley file has been cut  I tried to detect it, but it looks like my 3 4 buttons.
I'm sick of crabs and I'm out of ray shadow,
so I'm not detecting it, so I just deal
with
it.
Looking at the product introduction from day one, most of them show
similar results in one or another situation, so the analyst has to continuously discriminate this data,
but it continues to cause such discriminated difficulties.
This is the henna art power skill that suddenly popped up by applying the words in the trip. So when you activate all the things that match the characteristics, the
spectrum window's Chan additionally shows like this
.  It looks like it's real, it
's detached even if you just look at it. I'm sorry for the two weeks
.
Clinician Colli Paya was detected. However, after passing through it once, the detection was the same, but it is not because the foreign substance is not Ines's stomach
When the tower has a similar structure, this
mrm appears in abundance. That mrm changes the gram.
If we don't find 2 99 or 70 when counting at the end of the year,
.  If you set it
, you would have judged it that way from the beginning, saying
that this is just not at all, that is
, it
was not.  hair, and Nancy
I'm about to ride, but when I look at the sweater, a big ice pack trimer with me appears and
gives it to me.
Yes, we'll use hemp ram.
Let's look at the second advantage. It
's whipped with a body armor. If it's affected by the existing Miami matrix.
As a method, there is a way to analyze it again by experimenting with it
. However,
it is difficult to change the method because there is a method that has
been published and presented for 10 minutes.
There is no waist to apply in terms of performance. Then, in another way, another mrm was set again, but
if you try to do that, you have to see it in the news at the end of another time using a single standard substance
, so in fact, there is a part that takes too much time, but cm
rm  If it is already in the 2nd generation, you can change mrm with one check
and run reanalysis right away.
4 This is a real case of Taiwan's change by medium capacity
5 What kind of effect does the person who suffered a disaster have
?  I didn't like it, but in
2 or pepper, it was sprayed and sprayed very neatly before head rubbing, but
you can see such a bad size in brown rice.
There, too, one of the shares does
not
have a daughter.
mrm will already be 3 apps then like this  In the
case of a compound such as a crab bite sample, other companies have also
opted for the Yecheon system, and now
you can check and crush the chromatogram that does not receive good chromium
athene medium capabilities with a sad bar so that you can solve the data.  If you press another mrm that has been done and do a fraction like this, you can try
to make a moon because it would be a neat mrm in Taiwan, whether it was an existing problem
.
The app was done
But the addition also set pen a uh I checked if I said 138 oral and
100 89.0
relatively small but with 2m rm
I draw a clean chromatogram like this.
It
can't be a draw. Realism is good. It's good. He's not affected by the medium, and it's like smd.
Those Aion's have good sensitivity. Because they say that I can read
them.  You can get more accurate results when you do the analysis in
selection. Now, the trick is that it is made and used in Taiwan, so you
can see the results well just by selection.
Face s Yesterday I'll show you the power factor gate fold.
Everyone now has more than 90% of the medium, and when you do it all the way, you get a
5 ppb picture
.
You can see that the peak is stably clear or something else
. If you look at the heat in the computer, it is now 304 10 kinds, and
more than 300 has been hit with
most of the multi-role doctors, most of the compounds are 0.95  I think you will see the result that satisfies the ideal. Now that you see
Fiesta, parody is important
.
Most of the compounds in the pound were found to have 0.5 ppe of Eru d.
Yes, from this slide
, I will explain the various utilization coefficients in the practice of pesticide residues step by step.
Previously, Shiro's extracted processing, concentration, and the reduction and increase rate of the font target substance
were now considered and detected in the range of garlic recovery 1.
In other words, the
sample is injected and the sample is injected and the person goes to the s site through the column,
and the instruction is about the chat, so it crawls and can't run, so it
's up to 2 s to
knock it down.  The shank cannot be the same as the standard object
. Considering the parts that can make a difference in the therapy, you need to recognize it as the collection day. If you
look more closely at that part,
the matrix n concealment director's ability, but in
the first trial q, it was called fashion by using Aion.  Younha put Yuri on her shoulder. In the
actual sample, the witnessed component
appears lower than the original
one.  When I think about it, I extract and refine it and try to apply it,
but I can think that 20% of it will breathe, but it is
not
, and the recovery rate is typical of 100% in the calculation train.
It could be
that  More facts, now the difficult part is knowledge, maybe you can listen now with a different setting next time,
but the target component increases the sensitivity.
You can see the results by increasing the food by 200% 300% 500% in this way
.  Now that you know it,
it will be helpful.
Now, if you look at the matrix effect in the cms ms unique to 4 o'clock
, ios flash 4 ng appears in the elseif spray state.
After 7 years in the state of being a nightlife, the cub has to go through the level of Aion to find it.
In
particular, most of them are reduced.
So, actually, the fact that the peak appears small after the standard time
can cause symptoms.
Now, in order to further reduce this symptom, you
need to dilute and analyze the standard part of the quality search term
.
Oh, you have to take the dream of writing a reduction castle, and if
possible, you have to make a sample of the same medium every day
by diluting the same medium with enough samples and diluting the financial net.
And according to society, now in July  In the room to analyze the number of times or to purify the chief sheep
There is a law, but this part is because the things that go in like this are reduced, and in the
end, because you become a parent with a blue light like this as a slave,
it is reduced to therapy.  In
other words, you can do less kiss pushers now, and you can reduce the amount of chief
.
Since q is also very crumbly,
then it is not helpful to present the symptom representative to the chief, and if the chief makes a mistake or
prepares
less, it is not helpful.
This method is not applicable and the ability to reduce it is a way to be restrained in the bay by implementing this method.
In various situations, such as Oh Yu-mi or Some One large capacity depending on the experimental state
, the sensitivity may be
reduced or the part may be increased, or this may appear very much
.  Baking it once more and
changing it to 2 Geumyang and Suncheon stamina and analyzing it together is a
method called
Hyeoptak Geumyang Island.  If the pistil is the same, then if
you cool down again at the bottom rather than doing one hand of gold, and then
play and hold the alcohol again as standard, if you have a5 tea leaves, it will decrease to a high level.
If you do not know the graveyard, and
if you do the lunar new year, it will appear as much as the number of points.  If
you click the Brazing Calibration Nickel event of the app, the yoga
set will appear as an average value.
When you come out and go out, you can select the tool gk from the window outside.
Anyway, if you shout this kind of bakbo, you will change it and it will appear as one.
As the number of medicines has
risen properly, my 0.96 of the 0.98 triplet, which has been raised properly, shows results that are as high as 0.96,
so even if I try to have unreliable results in order to increase the result by using the stenotic shaded line,
another good result  You can see it as it is. So,
when you provide a cooperative oriental method for the pulse of an important sample for the joint volume, it will be helpful to use this process
to get the reduction win result to a good value
.
Next is weighting.
General  In fact, in the analysis, weighting
has not been applied much in the meantime, but
now, if you do this at the same time 5 ROM breaking Hoffen, in a way, the
long condition that I need to detect is a bit long
.  In some ways, the cost of the wedding ceremony can be seen from some equipment, which is a little easier to perform, and for
me, it can give you a waist exercise from the equipment.
I
'll be responsible for winning If
I think it will be compared to 123 But 1 ppb or spice appears high and
this pink appears
low and 300b appears that indie start
But here, if you turn off the bank blood, kendo can shark and y is x play  Russ
Pia Ski comes out with a good value. This is a problem.
Somehow, I make Yang Heungsu c,
but the value of en contraction is high, so 2 is quite large.
2 Starved. Fixing the part that distributes this keyword gives weight
It's a part, and it's
a bit copied quite a bit from time to time. Simply put, in
this case, if you give a weight, the money x is divided by 200,
that
is, the weight is divided by 100, 10 is divided by Osh, and
it is divided in this way.  It's
a part that weights a little more for me and middle school again. From
the same point of view, this
is
about data.  For this part, such as processing and manipulation for a
specific color, I manually sit down for a specific color and arrange it manually so that the number of
copies is stopped and then changed, but the scalpel is changed for a specific center.
The part that does is
now moving, and
when such a method is applied, all recent devices indicate that they have
been modified or display a different color.
It is picked and displayed last year. The
weight 10 is given like this. The Puss method is compared with 3,
and only calibration is performed, and the sample is also quantified under the same conditions
.
And the existing probably simultaneous multi-components are these institutions that have been doing it for a long time?
National Assembly rest 54
And now 200 won Now 197 98 How does it
appear?
You'll see,
this Benzai gets slightly worse and gets worse in very minute ways
.
Most of the points that came out at the end of the subtraction calculation
are unsuitable, so in fact, these fine errors are the part where there is no difference,
and it
hurts to kneel in the actual analysis.
There are cases like this.
Since such a low transfer is important, it is important how this low concentration mid
can be expressed with the opinion of adversity at the concentration under the discoloration. There is a
way to break it.
You have to adapt the drawing weight Oh, now I'll
give you a recommendation
Oh, next I'll explain the standard non-participation method
It can be seen as a way to analyze the matrix match by correcting the matrix base most accurately now
, but if you
explain the cathe, if there is a sample in the reduction, you have to look at it
like this
.
I put it in the same amount like this, and then
I put the standard substance there and the same
Yao Suzhou substance like this.
It will be
Here, a lot of counting times were sparked. The same amount. But
if you subtract 5 times, it will be 20 times
.
The Nash guitar man does the same thing again at the same time. Then, the basic volume is
calculated, and the part in this is the
same sample. In the end, the medium becomes the same, so the effect of the
medium appears the same.
Because it appears the same, the sample can be accurately evaluated. If you do this
, then the w will change.
If you read the plus, here is -25, then convert it to the blush value
and read it as 25, which is now convenient. In the case of unemployed participation, it
becomes the concentration.
I understood and made it all the time, but the
cover is very comfortable. If you do Po, the existing, now, the terrible Jangseon Act,
the Gospel Pharmacist Act, or my stamp play method, these parts are
now mechanically used for 4 situations,
but if you do this, oh this  -
I know that there are still quite a lot of people who do the calculation of the result in terms of how
to match the value plus, but you can try to contact the technology company.
I'm willing to come.
It's a function that is supported from the beginning.
Global 3 in dad window  If
you turn off the h&m 10007 scanned in the app, 2t
gigaah, this patch says that this sample was analyzed by the standard substance participation method,
so if it comes out as a negative value, then add the sentiment line and give the result a
nickname.
You can easily adapt to the method of recommending the volume without wanting to count it as a fellow
.
Even if you see
it, there will be a lot of cases where you are a bit long. But the easiest way to see
it is the expression recommendation method.
Uh, just by referring to the scandal, the
rt is not robbed and the peak does not keep coming out of the livestock,
but just like running the sale, the 0 point up of the beat man earlier appears like this in the frame.
There is a degree, and the standard comes
up like this. Then, the wedding company is at a
standstill.
I don't know, of
course, for those cells, you can check that with other things, such as Koreans or higher-level equipment,
but it's good if it's good, but in fact, it's most of the cases that don't work.
It is not a method, but it is actually used to judge diversity or
the amount of mentees. If you use it a lot as a way to properly manage the topsheet with accurate * management, it
will be very helpful in the actual product.
Yes Hemp is now a software called Heart  There will be this, that is
, the mass spectrometer from 70s to 18cm to ms ms and duff
lcms to duff lcms c m s ms This is the part where the same class is used the same way
.
People can use the temporary vote as it is. Because the sofa is the same, there are many parts. I
will use the parts that I did not buy a little more now
.  It was said that the unsuitable concentration value was automatically deleted, but
now the knowledge 600, the middle and late 200 of the 300 types of tubes, the
second half of the 200 tons, will now come out as the 200 types of test methods.
About 300 between departments, about 30 in Busan and Sichuan is
not enough. Solve this
Shima student. Oh, now you have to look
at 500 signboards.  If you say 30 to me, you have to see 5,000 even if it is just a few
, and if you tell me 30, you have to see thousands of cells.
You may not be able to see it, and you may miss a sample that is actually detected because it is actually mixed up
like this.
It’s annoying that this qualifier or pound has been made
.
There should be a little bit, it stretches to see if it fits or not.
There is a function that says, "I'll look at the other key because it's not detected at all, and don't do it for two days." There's also a value called "Solder to use the color vik paint area."
It just
indicates that
Yo level is the percentage for the lowest pad distribution concentration, and in the end,
if the cpu is the lowest concentration, it seems to be honest,
then if you put a ignorance here, then the top 3 alcohol is opposite to the area of ​​10 ppb
So, if I lose consciousness, if I take 500 of my 300 loss lines, I
immediately find the half area of ​​cpp for that, put the set hold value right away, and
it is automatically set so that I do not intellect less than that
.  Other than that, there is something almost like the 2nd generation of rupture.
Now, if the integer Nayeon is as large as the amount of Aion
, this Rachel is about 10% super and
if it moves in this range, it is right, right, it is easily sold, but if the
integer Nayoung is paired  In the small case, 10 ppb is not full of spring.
So it's deep, so I said to put up with the Peace Prize
.  Here, in this window, you went to apply the therapy from the window earlier. Lei Shen was
initially based on the Kelly fashion patch, the circumcision blister standard
.
Can
you look at it like this? I applied these parts. If
it goes out, it is now easier to get ten thousand cells, and only the sample with the pole detected remains like this,
so you can see
it by clicking.  In fact, it is a lot of power because
the chromatography is real  Which one of the best test methods to make sure that the peak is not made
is
the
chromatogram, which is the easiest, so
here is the part that it can take longer to compile if it goes to the master day view.
The parts listed as are the ones that appear after the peak that satisfy the condition while I have a fixed number of copies,
and
most of the thin bands shown here in orange are
those that do not satisfy those few generations.
If the qualifying race does not appear, it will
explode Well, if you set the noise ratio when you have time, the Glacier
bus is better  If you right-click after selecting it, you will return to that window earlier.
You can check it again accurately in the shell window. So, uh
, subtracting data like this while using a dual monitor is actually the most helpful because you can accurately fractionate many components
.  It will be helpful if you use 2 monitors to reduce the fatigue of data processing when performing multiple line repairs at the same time
.
Then there is the internal quality control part.
Now that Sophie has been made and now the unit is not of high quality 3, so you are managing the internal quality
well,
but the cage related to that level was realized
.
l1 ant If I made this internal clay
management sample like this, then I did the action with that color at once
From that lod to the road  All the values ​​will be displayed by week. You can
just use it as a cafe for the parts.
s Hunter has to do 100% of the office and Excel, so all these values ​​are
just copied and pasted in Excel, and you can easily
manage the internal quality  If you use these functions again, it will be helpful to use this concept more because
it becomes a part that can take more of my data reliability and manage the internal quality more easily
.  This hull group pack is quantitative.
Medicines that play well are ah data abilities. There are quite a lot of these organisms
.
Even if it is not a single case where it is divided and divided, it is mostly for North Korea, but if
those parts are not good enough and quantified separately as concentration, it
can be overestimated.
In
order to organize the combination of the two appearing like this, in the
mother sound window, add a compound group and a mat containing sword.
You can put a value and make
the same group with the same name here.
If you want to do it anywhere, by cleverness, and if you want to sum it,
click on this in the spot object, and the use of dollars is convenient,
so the credit rating of the Kelly business  When the concentration is OK,
it goes in automatically, so if you
put in the concentration and sell it, you will get a new room for this siler liquor and crab.
And now finally wrap
it in other 4 2+ or buy format is icon  You'll see
.
If you
are old enough, you can increase the amount of Picross by one, and you can see very neat results in your emotional state. If
you use such functions, no, it
seems to be more helpful for analysis.
No, I'll
do this. After making masses like this, you can save and arrange several generations. The number of
cigarettes you can unload today is 4, and it doesn't change on the computer while asking for another.
Yes, you can use it comfortably if you use it just like that without being released again by writing it
like
this. Yes, it is possible to provide a total solution according to the 10-minute disclosure
of talent.  Up to dm pd, all 1
of those parts can be used and provided at the same time, and besides that, we are now
providing more accurate Fusori, even the tip of the chin.
We are making and providing it quickly,
and if talent works now, one of the biggest advantages is that you have to do a lot of
work, but if there is no software uniformity, more will
come from unsplexed skills and the result will be pierced.
Because it is used, it is easy to access.
Wonhae Reliant is not simply selling machines, but is doing its best
to make a more accurate and convenient total solution in the analysis body fluid window.
to the end  Thank you
for listening. Yes, so far our house rental lcms hurts. The previous engine, Kim Ji-yoon Chai
, made an announcement
.
You explained well how to analyze easily while
doing
.
If you continue to register in the qna window, we will give you an answer live by Kim Joo-chan.
Then, first of all, you posted the contents of the first question
.  Yes, this is Kim Ji-
woon. You asked if the method is calculated in the average value method in
the sponsored gold Yangcheon method. Yes, that's right.
In fact, when each p is
expanded individually or when a point is made, it is wasteful to know, so it is the
same
with exp reduction.
You
did it. The formula itself is quite complex. It is really common in that part
.  The y can also
be given as a weight for the y-axis.
Giving assumptions about the concentration is explained again
earlier.  The high-concentration part was 200 tons earlier  If it's like a pill
, divide it by 200, divide it by the
number of days, and the part with a high concentration with flowers is now measured
for that much weight.
Low concentration and high concentration by concentration is
the part that fixes the part that wine s+ non-exam player watch absolutely like
that. You can understand it that
way.
If you do not apply the point complaint 6 value of the same iso stricken reputation method, if there is any
result, the pointer spreads to 3 feet in both hands.
So,
if you reduce the standard deviation and make one average value, the
drug price will improve so that you can do it
.
If the Geumyang line is different than when it was not used, it is
not good to know the basic line, so it is not good to know the basic line. So, especially when analyzing the results of agricultural products, especially
for the knowledge rather than the example qq, any stabilization line
increases the sensitivity for the column stabilization part  In that case, if
you use the agreement tang line method, you can do it. The value drops to 0.98 and
falls after the spiritual number 9.
So in such cases, it is recommended that you use the method of estimating the average in the low-volume method so that you can know.
4 You have asked the 3rd question now
.  If I tell you, this session was recorded so you can watch it again at any time
.  If you register your question, we will send an answer to the registered e-mail.
Please refer to it, check what you need for my viewing, and post your question
.
Yes, you said Yes
, I would be grateful if you could ask additional questions at any time.
Then, for now, I will go to the one with no additional questions and finish this session
. Thank you for stopping by today.
Thank you.